This brings us to the end of the course.
There are many more topics
that we could talk about, and
we encourage you to look at
the additional readings for the course.
As we said at the beginning,
we have had a lot of fun
putting this course together,
and we have learned a lot, too.
We hope you have enjoyed
the course as well.
>> We're also really eager
to get your feedback.
What did you enjoy about this course?
And what could have been improved?
What surprised you about this course,
either in the content or
in the way that it was administered?
Are there things that you've seen other
courses do that you wish we'd done, or
are things that we did that you'd
like to see other courses do?
>> We are very interested in your
answers to these questions, so
please feel free to contact either
one of us with your answers, and
fill out the course survey as well.
>> We'd also like to
thank several people for
helping make this course possible.
First, our video editor, Aaron,
who's done a phenomenal job making these
videos look so good and
frankly making us look presentable.
We'd also like to thank the rest of
you at Assety, especially Jenny Kim,
Jason Barrows, and Katie Reicult for
providing a great infrastructure for
course development.
>> We'd also like thank our
colleagues here at Georgia Tech,
including David White at
the college of computing.
And Mark Weston and
his staff at the Georgia
Professional Education Department.
It's been a real fun journey for us.
We expect to hear from you.
We hope it's the beginning
of a beautiful friendship.